hello and welcome today we're going to be
looking at what exactly happens when you do an
operation such as addition on two numpy arrays
of different shapes by the end of this video
you're going to understand why in this case
you should expect a three by three array
and you're going to understand where those
numbers come from and you're going to understand
what you would need to do differently
if you actually wanted to just
add number by number zero plus
three one plus four two plus five
so what is array broadcasting array
broadcasting is a way to do element-wise
operations on arrays of possibly different
but compatible shapes for example in this
case i have a matrix with two rows and three
columns and i have a single row of three numbers
in this case it's pretty clear that i can simply
add this row one two three to the top row and the
bottom row when i add it to the top row i get 1 3
5 and when i add it to the bottom row i get 4 6 8.
similarly if i added a column 1 2 instead of a row
then i would just add that column to each column
this idea works with any kind of element-wise
operation that you would want to do on arrays
so you can think plus minus times exponentiation
taking the minimum or maximum element-wise or lots
of other different functions if you're not sure
whether a certain function uses this kind of array
broadcasting just search for the word broadcast
in its numpy documentation before we can go on to
decide what it would actually mean to add these
two different arrays in a more general context
first we have to understand what it means for
the shapes of these two things to be compatible
obviously i can add one two three as a row
but would i be able to add 1 2 3 4 as a row
well no that doesn't really make sense and it's
kind of obvious why but it's still hard to explain
so here are the rules for determining if
the shapes of two arrays are compatible
it might look like a lot at first but stick
with me i promise we're going to do a lot of
examples and once you see a few examples
the rules are going to be crystal clear
first off if one of the arrays
has more dimensions than the other
then when you look at their shapes you should
right align them and imagine prepending ones
to the shorter one so if you had an array which
is just three numbers then you could just as well
think about it as a one by three array or a one by
one by three array or a one by one by one by three
array it doesn't matter how many ones you prepend
to the front of the shape that doesn't change that
there's just three numbers in there the next rule
is that if an axis has just a single element in it
then you can repeat or broadcast that axis to the
length of the other vector's axis all remaining
axes must have the same lengths so using these
rules we'll be able to compute whether arrays are
compatible and if so what the broadcasted shape
the results of the broadcasted operation will be
again these look a little complex but once
you see the examples it'll clear right up
so here's the first example we start with an x
that we assume has shape two by three of course
something with the exact same shape must be
compatible so in this case another two by
three array would be compatible but there are
definitely other things that are compatible
so we could have a two by one array and we
see that that's compatible because the twos
match and then one can match with anything
so the one matches with the three that's okay
similarly a one can match with a two and a three
can match with the three those are compatible and
whenever you see something that's shorter than the
other one you prepend ones until they're the same
length so you should imagine that it looks like
this in which case it's the same as the previous
thing the one matches with the two and the three
with the three so in that way if i have an array
of just three elements that still matches with a
two by three array in this case the broadcasted
shape is going to be two by three now what are
some examples of things that are not compatible
well a three by two is not compatible because a
three doesn't match a two and also a two doesn't
match a three we are not allowed to reorder
the axes when checking for compatibility
in this last example you might think that it would
be compatible because it's like a two by one but
not so the rule is always to prepend ones so if
i do that i add one at the beginning not the end
in that case i would have something
that looks like one by two
the one matches with the two but the two does not
match with the three so they're not compatible
if you wanted to do 2 comma 1
instead you would just have to
reshape y using the dot reshape method
let's look at another set of examples
in this case we have 4 dimensions and we see
that all of the following things are compatible
in every case we follow the same rules again
though in this case we cannot append a one to
make it compatible we always prepend ones so far
we've only seen examples where the resulting shape
is the same as one of the original shapes let's
look at an example where that is not the case
in this example we have quite different
looking shapes but they are in fact compatible
you can see in this case that i've already right
aligned them and that they match up every entry
either is the same number or has a one in the
column and then of course i would just prepend
ones in this space but i'll leave that out so the
way that we're getting the common shape is to take
either the common number in this case 17 or one
or if only one of the numbers is 1 then take the
number that's not that so we would take 17 here
1 here 11 here 7 here 5 here and then 3 2 and 1.
so now you should be able to tell just by
looking at the shapes of the two arrays
whether they're compatible and if so what the
resulting shape should be but i still haven't told
you how to actually add two things of different
shapes to do that all we have to do is imagine a
for loop the idea is that for any dimension where
you used a one to match a different dimension
then instead of looping over that variable just
use index 0 because that's the only valid index
in this case i have a 3x3 and a 3x1 so we check
that the shapes are compatible 3 matches with 1
and three matches with three the
resultant shape should be three by three
i then create an empty array of that shape and
i'm going to use nested for loops to fill in
the values of course actually using these for
loops would be a bad idea because for loops in
python are extremely slow but to understand what
value numpy is actually computing when you do this
this is what you should be thinking of
okay so in order to fill out the ijth entry
of our output array just think that you want
to do element-wise addition but when it's not
possible fill things in in the best possible
way x has shape 3 3 so it makes sense to give
i and j as indices to the x array y on the
other hand was 3 by 1. so it makes sense
to pass in the i index which goes from zero
to two but i can't pass in the j index here
because that axis only has one
element it only has one valid index
so just use it if i go ahead and run the code we
see that the output is the same as what numpy gave
let's take a look at another example this
example shows how to think about it when you had
one array that didn't have as
many dimensions as the other
and the rule here is just omit the variables
whenever you prepended ones to the dimension
in this case i have x which is a two by
three by three which is essentially it's
two three by three matrices there's one
and there's the other and i have a single
three element array we right align the dimensions
and we can tell that they're compatible three
three three matches one and two matches one and
the resultant shape is two by three by three
this time i have three nested loops
because the shape is three dimensional
to figure out what goes in the ijk spot of the
output array we just look at what to do for each
element x has no problem because it has shape
two by three by three but with y there's only
one dimension so what to do with the first two
dimensions well since they were pretended to be
length 1 anyway all we were going to do is plug
in 0s there so let's just omit them the way that
i know to plug in k here instead of i or j is that
i'm thinking of this column as corresponding to i
this column as corresponding to j and this column
as corresponding to k so you can see that for y i
have enough dimensions to plug in the index again
when i run the code you can see that the output of
the numpy calculation is identical to
the output created using the for loops
in this final example let's look back at the one
that we started with on the title slide we had a
three by one array and a one by three array
this highlights the fact that you can have
ones in either of the arrays not just one of
them by now we can calculate the compatible shape
three matches with one and three matches with
one so the resultant shape will be three by three
so we create an empty array of that
shape and loop over the two dimensions
the output at i j is computed as follows
the first dimension corresponds to i and we know
that in that dimension x has the same shape as the
output so it makes sense to plug in the index
i there but for j x only has one thing in it
so let's just use the only valid index 0. on
the other hand for y it is the i dimension
that only has one valid index so we plug in zero
but for the j dimension we can plug in the index j
so now we see where this three by three answer
comes from and you can check that our answer is
the same as the numpy one so now can you tell
what would you do if you wanted to just add
zero and three one and four and two and five
well the answer is you would just reshape one
of them you could either reshape this one
to one by three or this one to three by one
or both of them just to a three element array well
i hope this video helped you understand a little
bit better about what numpy array broadcasting
is and why it gives you the answers that it does
if you're looking to test your skills
a little bit here's an exercise for you
suppose you have a thousand images that are 32 by
32 pixels and each image has three color channels
so it's your standard red green and blue pixel
values from 0 to 255. so every pixel has a red
value a green value and a blue value now suppose
you have all this image data stored in a single
array of size n c w h here n is your 1000 images
c is the three channels w is the width and
h is the height so my question for you is what
array y would you multiply by to scale every red
pixel by 2 every green pixel by 3 and every blue
pixel by four if you want to check your answer
check out the github link in the description
which has the source code for this notebook
thanks for watching don't forget
to like comment and subscribe